pues revela las graves fallas de la
maquinaria eclesiástica tanto en los
estados unidos como en el vaticano
durante cinco décadas a lo largo de
cuatro pontificado desde pablo sexto
hasta el papá francisco las primeras
denuncias de abusos sexuales de
mccartney llegaron en los años 80 si a
pesar de esto matar y que siguió su
ascenso en la jerarquía de la iglesia
católica pasando de ser un simple
párroco a obispo auxiliar de nueva york
a obispo de metiche el arzobispo de
newark y después arzobispo de washington
la sede más prestigiosa de los eeuu
finalmente pues nombrado cardenal de la
iglesia católica en el año 2001 por el
papa juan pablo segundo antes de este
nombramiento juan pablo segundo había
pedido aclaraciones sobre los rumores
las denuncias de abusos sexuales de
macca rick según el informe que acaba de
ser publicado en el vaticano 3 de los
obispos americanos consultados en esta
época y proporcionaron informaciones
inexactas
completas a la santa sede sobre la
conducta sexual de matar
natalia es que este escándalo ha sido
tremendo para el pontificado actual le
pregunto por qué
pues porque un anuncio un antiguo
embajador de las santas en los eeuu en
el año 2018 acusó al papá francisco de
estar al tanto y de encubrir a mccartney
que se trata de monseñor carlo maría
viganó a un opositor del papá francisco
quien pidió hablar la renuncia del papá
francisco eso desató una tormenta en el
pontificado actual y dio pie para una
investigación que duró dos años y que
fue el origen del informe que acaba de
ser publicado en el vaticano un informe
que concluye con un mea culpa de la
santa sede que reconoce graves fallas
que favorecieron la impunidad de los
crímenes de mazzarri y que aboga por que
estas conductas no se reproduzcan en el
futuro